foreign
comes from Cindy and Nevada
I'm happy to say that we are enjoying
baby step 7 Building Wealth and giving I
do have a few close friends who
frequently criticize me for not having a
credit card only a debit card they tell
me I'm putting myself at high risk for
fraud and that I am not protected can
you please clarify how a debit card is
safe
uh well this is a common misconception
when it comes to credit card or to debit
cards so the best way to do it is when
you run your debit card is to hit
actually credit and sign your name
versus Hit debit and do your PIN number
because when you hit credits it's not a
credit card it's still coming out of
your account as a debit card but it's
run through the same system as it would
a credit card so you get all of the
protections that a credit card would
have but you're having it with a debit
card so it is a safe they they will have
the same protection policy with your
debit card
yeah and um
so Cindy uh
uh you can tell her to get new friends
how to say this yeah no no I'm not but
um
you are wealthy
you have no debt
you have control of your money you're
incredibly generous you should be
telling other people how to handle their
money and not broke people telling you
how to handle money that's good and so
you know just I mean I they are not on a
credible footing to tell you anything
about anything
money-wise
um and so but here's the deal if you
want to
I don't argue with people like this I
just ignore them but including the ones
in my personal life okay so it's just
you know whatever you want to do do it
um but if you want if you personally
want to understand just go to visa.com
or mastercard.com they have in their
fine print that you can look in the card
member agreement there's a paragraph
that says zero liability policy and the
zero liability policy that says that in
the event your card is misused debit or
credit fraudulent transactions you are
responsible for zero
period they have a zero liability policy
the customer is not responsible in a
debit card use with Mastercard or VISA
in their own terms and conditions on
their website is not responsible for a
penny
so you are zero at risk more using a
debit card than you are using a credit
card that is absolutely false
it is a it's mythology that the debit
card is more dangerous the only
difference is if you if I use my debit
card at a hotel and a hotel uh clerk
steals the number
writes it down while they're you got my
card or something and then they go and
buy something that night with it and
they run it and my my bank doesn't catch
it and it comes out of my account
it might be a day or two before they put
the money back
that's the only difference
and I have never had that happen and I
have been using debit cards since the
day they came out and have not had a
credit card in 35 years
and I walk the earth
just fine and I know we kind of rag on
banks a lot but I'll say I'll be honest
the bank I have with my debit card
they're so on it with fraud charges like
they will they'll wear me out yes but I
like it because I'm like thank you for
at least being on top of it and
thankfully none of it is it's all my
transactions well they wear you out
because it's their money that they're
going to lose yeah but they're always on
it it's most banks are on it which is
great they're fraud algorithms on on
credit or debit uh most of most of us
and they're walking around in America
today get a call a week or a call every
two weeks of some kind is this is really
your charge and so like I have to tell
them if I'm going out of the country
Sharon or going on vacation don't deny
all our charges you know which is good
though I know I know but it's not the
point it's a pain in the butt but the
that is because the bank knows that visa
and MasterCard says they are liable not
you
and so you are not at risk of losing
substantial sums of money or any sum of
money due to fraud or any kind of high
risk activity so your friends are just
wrong
it's that simple they just don't know
what they're talking about now again how
forceful you want to be with that
argument or how much you just personally
want to be comfortable with the idea is
fine I have a bunch of friends that use
a credit card and paid off every month
and they have a lot of money and um and
they just you know and and some of them
probably believe this crap but I just
don't have this discussion with them I'm
not going to talk to them about it I
carry a debit card there's not a chance
I have a credit card under any situation
ever again I'm not going to ever be in
debt especially to a stupid Bank